one of my one of my guests of this hour
is in studio who is a rarity in terms of
a head and heart all together in the
same body and a successful career that
deserves all the kudos that you deserve
Eddie George good to see you thank you
thank you for having me rich and
congratulations on this is all thank you
thank you my success to your show I
appreciate that you are one of 29 men to
walk the planet Earth
with 10,000 rushing yards in the history
of the National Football League but only
two ran for 10,000 yards without missing
a single start that would be Jim Brown
and you really had no idea is that right
okay you've jinxed so modest yeah - what
do you attribute that cuz I know
Marshall talks a lot about moving his
body in the hold of it trying not to get
that full on yellow but you would you
would hit people yours look at my size
compared to Marshall yeah our show had
the hips the quick feet right you know
he was more of a scat back type might
you know me being you know 6-3 and
playing at 2:45 at the time I had to use
my size to my advantage and I would plow
through guys and I would make him miss
occasionally but that would that was my
style and you used to tangle with Ray oh
all the time you and Ray Lewis a paint
swapping affair is you just dispatched
with London Fletcher right there yeah
that was slouched and just this is the
Super Bowl obviously what was it like
going up against somebody like Ray would
you get ready for that specific way it
was the week of right the game cocaine
against Baltimore you had to get your
mind and spirit prepared not the body
because the body was gonna do what it
has to do because you know it wasn't a
game was when we play 59 59 minutes 59
seconds it was 60 minutes of war with
him and he was so smart in terms of
where he was we you know he want to run
getting the defense together I mean
he was just that intelligent and you
just had to watch him because he can
catch you at any moment and they can he
can he can knock you out the game I mean
it was that that physical and he would
Joe would go back and forth drawn bout
you know who was the best and we were
the best teams at the time and you know
he had my number he owned me and you
know we'd go back and forth but those
are some classic battles that I always
look back on between the Titans and the
Ravens before the divisions yeah you
used to play twice a year oh the sense
of the AFC Central right with Pittsburgh
twice Jacksonville it was us yet
Baltimore Cleveland Cincinnati
this was the Coughlin era Jackson oh yes
people were hitting me Fred Fred Taylor
four tick Corey Dillon Jerome Bettis
those were the type of running backs in
our division this is the days and we
played the telephone booth yes okay sure
it was it was no joke no joke so and one
year you ran for 402 403 attempts in the
2000 season we're seeing DeMarco Murray
run at a pace right now that would make
that look like you were just having a
walk in the park
yeah so what what do you think he is
going through right now right now since
it's so early in the year he's he's
probably loving life he's feeling pretty
good but you have to remember those
amount of carries will accumulate and
along with that comes a ding of a need
an injury here separated ribs a shoulder
something is going to happen I know it
looks great now but if they want to win
a championship it's going to go through
him and that offensive line they got to
keep him healthy they got a dial back
the carries split the carries allow him
just to get you know no more than 20 a
game that they can try to reach for that
goal because once you start getting into
30 plus 40 and you're really relying on
him he runs the risk of injury in the
last two years he's been injured and I
think he is the key cog that's that's
not a success right now he's awesome in
that offensive line they're crushing it
right now take a lot of pressure off of
Tony Romo what did you feel how did you
feel though in 2001 after all those 2000
carry I had well I had to get toe
surgery which really
me back in my career I couldn't train it
all that offseason I had to get a total
reconstruction of my toe and it took me
a full year to get back that was my
worse it's just a fiscal year in 2001
yes he'll never missed a game it was it
was horrific it felt like I was running
on a flat tire that makes sense where I
couldn't have the balance in my toe
bouncing off to my uh terms of my
explosion toe injuries no joke we've
been saying that with AJ Green having
suffered in this past weirdo anytime
Deon takes his shoe off we tell him to
put a shoe back on because that's how
his career wrapped up those toe injuries
are no joke people think that it's all
it's a toe no it's where all your weight
is being shortlist and you have the
explosion the cutting ability and you
become a different player after that so
what would you counsel the Cowboys to do
right now because it is all working and
it is balanced and it is a winning style
of football now we did see Joseph Randle
carry very well and you know there's
Dunbar there as well we don't know what
you know what's gonna happen with
Randall after he had a what was he
thinking about obviously you think about
smelling good and feeling good the
questions
gucchi okay again these are all these
are all according to reports but what
would you tell the Cowboys to do because
it's if it's working because they have
Giants and the Eagles coming oh yeah oh
yeah they have to keep winning football
Arizona's coming in in a couple weeks
and that might be the game for the NFC
League for the conference I mean they've
got some some big-time games coming up
and I think what they're gonna have to
do is really try to spread the wealth
with that and be careful with him and
because now you're getting to the meat
of the season like you said the table
love for the playoffs and it's tempting
to say okay we got DeMarco let's keep
feeding them which is good but when you
think about November football and
certainly December football that's where
you want to need him the most
so I'm Dallas and they're smart about
this given his history with injury
you dial him back a little bit you reel
him back in because you don't want him
approaching that 400 carry mark and
given where Tony Romo is in terms of his
confidence and he's protected now he's
able to see the field better he's not
making dumb mistakes and you're leaving
you're not putting the game in his hands
in the fourth quarter you kind of want
to find who else can do other things in
terms of the backfield to keep the
pressure off him a little bit 245 yards
ahead of the next most prolific rush of
his Le'Veon Bell and he is no slack he's
got a running style I imagine you would
love them
I love I love him back at Michigan State
and what's what's beautiful about him is
how he's mastered his craft I mean he's
lost weight I think he's down like 25
pounds from two years ago and just his
feet he sees the hole with his feet yes
you see like like what is that buddy
made by that he can he can like he can
see his speak and get in and out of
tight spots like where you're I see but
his feet can do it and he's worked very
hard in the offseason to work on that
part of his game that he can do it a
little too much where you know you get
too excited you want to make people miss
but once he learns the the balance
between one cut and go and then doing a
double cut inside of a hole and getting
up field that's when he's really going
to become that guy I love his running
style and and the Steelers need him
obviously with for an offense that has
otherwise a quarterback well they will
antenna Antonio Brown is balling out
this year too but if it's too much Ben
and brown and a lot of other green
receivers they need I mean bells is sort
of the bell cow well here's the thing
Saint Pittsburgh these to find out who
they are offensively because they
haven't been able to score the last
couple of weeks they have their lacked
an identity you need to go back to what
Pittsburgh is used to doing that's
running the football first establishing
the runner and allow Ben to operate off
the play action pass the the running
back du jour though is Brandon Oliver in
San Diego I'm just I love watching him
play he's just he's hit in the century
mark in his first couple of
outings either receiving or running
mm-hmm and Philip Rivers is finding
every possible receiver but he looks
just like Sproles he wears this he looks
exactly like running style no it's
amazing the same number and you know he
can if he can do it all and what's he
showing he can do or in that offense
with everything this the charges look
like the team to beat out of the AFC and
he's a you think so huh when you look at
it I mean I've seen the plague in
Seattle and the way they punked Seattle
early in a year I was very impressed
with that and now they had the balanced
defense they had the balance offensively
with Philip Rivers and now Brandon about
he's Oliver's is coming to fruition for
their offense San Diego is going to be
it's going to be a very interesting
playoffs come up this year you're living
in Nashville living in Nashville okay so
what do you make of the Titans running
game right now I mean that's seeming
sporadic it's Sankey's job right now to
take isn't it yeah well they try to to
bring in Shawn green and it had a
cluster come in from decima cluster from
Kansas City they wanted to do a running
back by committee but since G Locker has
gone down and the office can't run
through him Charlie Whitehurst is now on
the starting quarterback yeah for the
foreseeable future so now they got to
find a guy that can rely on the Bishop
Sankey is the future and the running
back position but the Titans have a ton
of problems on the defensive side of the
football that they're trying to resolve
they got it they got away with the win
this weekend but they really got to
figure some things out moving forward so
I'm you're you can you stay for another
second man I'm here to talk to you about
I appreciate that I want to talk with
with you about life after football which
includes acting for you yes you're a
thespian are you an act or I'm an act
tour okay act cool you know there's a
difference
as you know right yeah and acting is an
actor you know I'm an actor an act tour
means that you can you can carry a
Shakespearean on plus I'm an act or
you're an act toward I'm we're gonna put
you to the Rich Eisen show test alright
coming up next we'll see if you can act
Shakespeare
with my till to full our sound that if
you can do that then you give me
prologue way as your future hunter let's
call it automatic thing scene 2 of
Othello a bedchamber in the castle
Desdemona you're asleep you're in bed
asleep enter Othello have you prayed
tonight Desdemona
ah my lord it if you bethink yourself of
any crime and reconciled is yet to
heaven grace solicit for it straight my
lord what do you mean by that
do it and be brief I will walk why I
would not kill thy unprepared spirit no
heaven for a friend I would not kill thy
soul talk of you killing I I do
I hope yet I fear you when your eyes
were also I do not why I should fear
since illness I know not but yet I feel
I fear thank one thy sins some bloody
passion shakes your frame
these are portents but yet I hope I hope
that handkerchief which I so loved and
gave thee thou gavest to Cassio sweet
soul take heed take heed of perjury thou
art one died deathbed I but yet not to
die yes presently therefore can first
eat freely of I sin for to deny each
article with oath cannot remove nor
choke the strong conception that I do
groan withal thou art to die Wow it's
odd into here now I have to kill her
right now
please seriously Eddie I don't know how
we could top that
but how is that for you Mike was that
good staging a little off for you Eddie
I'm sweating it's like I get old Tuesday
here also plus I think the only previous
acting experience you played Willy Wonka
no gift great right when you were the
understudy for Willy Wonka yes that was
yeah it was understudy I never was the
name welcome back
there's my University of Michigan
journal number 90 I was class of 90
that's not because I'm a defensive
lineman by trade 98 on Devon Garden
looks awful that's probably what you
know after they beat Notre Dame II wore
12 like last season that's the last that
we've seen oh I got into trouble on
Twitter saying it was time to take the
Thom Hartmann Jersey back yeah just
listen I got Mark Harmon his son you
know who's on America's most watched
networks America's most watch program
NCIS said his dad would be fine with it
so if he says his dad's fine with that
I'm fine were that I love watching Devin
Gardner play it's a little bit maddening
sometimes yes get off the subject
let's give him tea you know we just had
fun with you acting and with Mike Dell
to fo and you seriously making him look
like Brad Pitt could be your best work
oh thank you I appreciate so why acting
why are you turning to that oh you know
what once I stopped playing about nine
years ago I wanted to get into
television and commentating and I was a
little nervous because of the cameras
you know with the red lights and also I
want to feel more comfortable sure with
that so I saw it with an acting coach
and found that it doesn't translate
you know from theater to television but
what I did find I found a passion for
acting in terms of character development
and writing and taking a lot of that
pent-up energy that I had playing
football the frustration and display
that through characters and I got into
reading the classics got into the
Shakespeare did a few plays and I Scott
the acting bug for it and never stops
sense it was it's truly amazing it's
awesome and what what how old were you
when you retired I was 31 see so many
people don't think about this
because they watch you play and they've
watched folk Marshall I think retired at
age 34 yeah and so many kids coming out
of college high school right playing
your position if they we told them
listen would you want any George's
career they'd be absolutely I'll take
any George's career but that means you'd
have to find something else to do with
your life at age 31 and you put so much
energy and time and effort and faith
into building a career and I have had a
really awesome one but you wake up from
that dream right and then you have to go
on to find another mountain to climb
that's worthwhile that's aligned with
your life purpose and that's tough a lot
of guys can't divorce themselves from
the identity of a being a football
player sure it's very tough to do
especially when you're the big man on
campus just drafted in the National
Football League in the NFL and the
Players Association at the rookie
symposium spend a large amount of time
and they wring their hands leaning up to
the event to figure out the best ways to
get through to a lot of these guys half
the room half this room of big men on
campus will be out of football by the
age of 26 on average somebody's on
average and some of these guys get it
and figure out like I need another
career starting now while I'm playing
football and but you don't you can't
really blame some of these other guys
for thinking differently and just in
that regard well you know what it's
funny you mentioned X I was at the
rookie symposium last year and you're
after that's a great fill you should be
speaking it so they do an outstanding
job of bringing this stuff to light for
a lot of these guys but you have to
think that it's a one-off so once they
leave the rookie symposium and go into
their lives as being football players to
pursuing that dream they tend to forget
those messages that were learned so what
I've been doing an alignment with Ohio
State and the Fisher School of Business
is creating a curriculum to help bring
the stuff to light so you consider
school at Northwestern I went to Kellogg
that's what the Kellogg MBA
good but it really is one of those deals
where they need to hear the language see
the players the people involved agents
GM's owners family members and hear the
stories and case studies surrounding
those people so it's nothing new to them
once or if they get into the position of
being a professional football player so
you begin to think beyond the game of
football not just saying okay I've
reached the pinnacle the height of being
a professional football player now at
the age of 35 or 40 it's done so tough
to do though oh yes so tough to do and
even making that transition from from
the field to television as an analyst
it's that is not easy yes it's not when
the red light comes on yeah you feel
comfortable in the beginning you're like
okay you lose all your thought you can't
speak proper English I mean it's it's
daunting to feel the heat of the lights
it's so much going on and to have a cop
one one thought that you're focused on
and have to get out in 15 seconds or
less and then you have a producer in
your ear then you have a smart-aleck
ghost exactly right so so where do you
see your acting career go are you doing
like theater in now doing theater in
Nashville I have been for the last four
years so I could go buy ticket and I can
go see Eddie George doing what what the
whipping man this January the end of
January early February I'll have the
exact dates yet okay when it's the
whipping man's a brilliant play with a
three-man play based off a time in
history when the civil war ends and it's
literally three people two slaves two
former slaves and the son of the slave
owner that comes back to a house they're
celebrating the Jewish holiday holiday
on a seder and it's just a fascinating
writing in terms of where these guys are
going to go after the Civil War so it
relates to me because I've been through
that like what I'm doing after my life
at the football sure but in this period
in time it's about slaves in how
all they're going to adapt to this new
life it's really well written February
5th through the 21st have it at the
Andrew Johnson theater yeah so come so
hopefully know this into the years after
the Superbowl my schedule is a little
free I'm probably gonna spend a lot of
time with my kids at home and wife and
kids at home but maybe on my way to the
combine come through I can come through
Nashville on the way to India now I'll
get you a front-row seat that's the way
I'm a custody now I I don't want to
correct you because you said you're
you're you're doing some work through
Ohio State and the Fisher School at Ohio
State yes isn't it the yes it is yes it
is the obvious way that in all
seriousness now it's been everyone you
know it is you enjoy it you enjoy it
seems to one your higher Ohio State
nobody's getting middle one only means
form you something nobody is getting
mixed up as to which Ohio State it is
nobody there isn't a soul on the planet
that when you hear Ohio State is playing
so-and-so or Ohio State has gone ahead
and well I can't sit there and say made
an academic breakthrough but I mean I
could sit here and say nobody is sitting
here and wondering which Ohio State you
don't have to but they know is the the
one and only the great however you want
to whatever adjective you want to put
behind that I own Chris Carter who by
the way is the best speaker I've ever
seen the rookie symposium yeah have you
have you ever Chris have you seen him
speak there did he speak there this year
and this seems speak of this symposium
but I've heard him speaks on several
occasions he on believe because this
will also teach these kids to is you
know watch out your rookie season you're
a target you're a target when you go out
you're a target when you go online
you're a target on social media and they
will give him a warning
my favorite line Chris Carter got up
there and said when you go to the club
if you go to a club if you go anywhere
and suddenly a lot of ladies are coming
up to you and talking to you just know
this you're not that good-looking
krispy kreme Sylvia me in without Bobby
alright so if I could give you a if I
could give you a role that you'd want to
play oh wow
let's get this out here people did I
want people in this town there's theater
people that are out there know what I
want to do a role like on the house of
cards okay like the role that Kevin
Spacey please I mean that that's let's
try and get you on house of cards period
that will be cool I can let's work our
way towards Lee that wants to be mayor
that know what you that's not typecast
you come on we're giving you the we up
I'm giving you an opportunity we're not
typecast you as an athlete you becomes
this you are on out you're on Capitol
Hill uh-huh or your staffer right we're
politician you're a lobbyist lobbying
how about your lobbyist for the Screen
Actors Guild I like that
how about that she you should be my we
can forget this job this time I will
take 10% I'll take 15 season that's
another thing that the athletes can't
handle when they come and have work for
the paparazzi I never sent two agents
you're like no it's a big deal yeah a
million is really not a million ten
percent you know wait a minute because
athletes are not used to giving 10
percent of their salary hey no no no
playing field Eddie you're a good man
thanks for having that Eddie George 27
27 the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience